welcome to the broad Meadow
refurbishment
presentation the following images allow
us the chance to offer you a visual
representation of the proposed
refurbishment and decarbonization works
at Broad Meadow Sports
Center image one this image outlines the
existing ground floor plan showing the
Sports Hall to the top left moving
across to the gym before the Squash
Courts with the second Gym area below
the squash court the annex building
shows the current change in toilet and
office
areas image two the existing first floor
plan shows the studios that are used
primarily for exercise classes and
indoor cycling
classes image three the blue areas noted
on the plan indicate the proposed gym
extension achieved by removing some
smaller areas of internal walls and
moving into the second squash Cor
area these changes will enable the
targeted growth to the gym
facilities a new downstairs exercise
studio will be created using Court space
from the Sports Hall that will allow
exercise program growth and enable the
opportunity for an accessible studio for
our current and future
users alongside female and male toilets
changing and shower facilities a village
changing area will create accessible
changing areas for those needing
supported access
including family changing areas private
showers with changing cubicles are also
planned in this
area the reception entrance will be
relocated to the car park side of the
building providing users with easier
access to the
center image four the main exercise
studio will extend across the newly
created downstairs Studio enabling a
greater Studio capacity that will
provide more space for users to attend
excise ex classes and activities the
indoor cycling studio will be extended
slightly to increase the capacity in
this area
too image five here is a visual
representation of the proposed new
reception entrance which will be more
conveniently located for our users to
access the
center Image six the existing building
elevations are noted on this slide
image seven proposed elevations are
Illustrated the west elevation shows the
outside of the indoor cycling Studio to
the top right of the first
image cladding is proposed to reduce the
thermal gains experienced in this area
to help maintain a more suitable
exercise
environment alongside improved air
Handling Systems planned internally will
maintain more appropriate
temperatures the north elevation shown
in the bottom image offers a further
indication of the proposed new reception
entrance of the
facility our consultation runs until the
19th of January 20124 and we would
welcome your
feedback